if you are reading some number of pages
every single day and it's useful stuff
good fiction or useful non-fiction you
are going to be learning so much more
than the average person who's reading no
books no books at all I used to have a a
sort of like a minimum I wanted to read
25 non-fiction Pages a day and then some
fiction at night before going to bed
I've recently upped it to 30 pages a day
of nonfiction if I'm reading 80 books a
year or whatever it ends up working out
to be and someone else is reading zero
that's an insane leg up whether I'm
interviewing for a job or just for
personal Enlightenment and knowledge or
being an interesting person with things
to talk about if I'm reading 80 books
and you aren't reading any
that's going to create a big big gap in
enjoyment in knowledge in all of these
different things